Atomic Energy Agency is responsible for
monitoring all of this and investigating
any suspicious activity how's it working
well it's working very well so far I
mean this is not a bilateral agreement
it's not just something that President
Obama negotiated but our European allies
Russia and China with Iran and so far
the agreement has knocked back Iran's
capacity to produce the material for
nuclear weapons it would take over a
year for them to amass enough highly
enriched uranium for just one nuclear
weapon and then they'd have to do much
more it would take more time in order to
actually put together in nuclear weapon
so this is in place if the two sides
fully implement the agreement it will
ask for well over a decade what's
unfortunate is that President Trump
continues to say that this is a bad deal
he doesn't explain why it's a bad deal
and he has talked about renegotiating it
somehow there is no renegotiation of
this very complex agreement the other
threat to this agreement is that some
members of Congress want to put more
pressure on Iran for their other
behavior in the region and some of them
are proposing legislation they could re
impose the very sanctions the
nuclear-related sanctions that were
lifted under the terms of this 2015
agreement if that happens that could
begin to unravel the nuclear deal and
open up the bigger problem which would
be a resurgent Iranian nuclear program
that could eventually lead to a nuclear
weapon or a war over that very issue in
the region in future years so it's very
important I think for President Trump to
continue the current course to
vigorously implement this agreement to
make sure that Iran is complying
checking with what the International
Atomic Energy Agency is seeing on the
ground and to think about what can be
done in year 10 and 12 and 15 of the
agreement to extend some of those very
important restrictions on Iran's program
that will begin to expire in about a
decade so he has some time to put
together a comprehensive agreement that
might involve other countries in the
region
to extend some of those limits that
right now are just focused on Iran and
Iran alone our conversation is with
Darrell Kimball he is a graduate of
Miami of Ohio is the former executive
director of the coalition to reduce
nuclear dangers and currently serves as
the executive director of the Arms
Control Association if people want to
follow you on Twitter how can they do so
I'm at Darryl G Kimball on Twitter and
the arms Control Association is at arms
control now we have a lot of information
about all these issues analysis news
reporting you'll find quite a lot of
ways to stay informed and stay engaged
and I would really encourage people to
do this because we have an array of
nuclear related challenges that require
information and a well-informed public
and policymakers and the website is arms
control org exactly thank you very much
for stopping by
we appreciate it thank you on behalf of
the president the role of First Lady's
the newest book by our next guest who is
joining us from San Francisco Lauren
Wright also a member of a group of the
educators involved in the White House
transition project she's joining us next
on this president's day Monday
you're watching c-- span's washington
journal we're back in a moment
[Music]
so which presidents were America's
greatest leaders c-span recently asked
91 presidential historians to rate our
43 presidents in 10 areas of leadership
top billing this year went to the
president who preserved the Union
Abraham Lincoln he's held the top spot
for all three c-span historians surveys
three other top vote-getters continued
to hold their positions George
Washington Franklin Roosevelt and
Theodore Roosevelt Dwight Eisenhower who
served in the Oval Office from 1953 to
1961 makes his first appearance in the
c-span top 5 this year now rounding out
the historians top 10 choices Harry
Truman Thomas Jefferson John F Kennedy
and Ronald Reagan Lyndon Johnson jumps
up one spot this year to return to the
top 10 but pity Pennsylvania's James
Buchanan he's ranked dead last in all
three c-span surveys and there's bad
news for Andrew Jackson as well our 7th
President found his overall rating
dropping this year from number 13 to
number 18 but the survey had good news
for outgoing President Barack Obama on
his first time on the list
historians placed him at number 12
overall and George W Bush moved three
spots up on the scale to 33 overall with
big gains in public persuasion and
relations with Congress how did our
historians rate your favorite president
who are the leaders and the losers in
each of the 10 categories you can find
all this and more on our website at
c-span org
tonight on the communicators National
Association of Broadcasters CEO gordon
smith looks at the future of television
as a new republican-controlled FCC ways
changes to the communications landscape
mr. Smith is interviewed by morning
consult technology reporter Amir Nasser
ATS 3.0 on the television side holds
enormous promise for the American people
for the consumers not just for
broadcasting but it it lets you do data
casting it lets you do the best pictures
that are out there immersive sound and
internet operability and so I think his
making that on their putting it right up
there on their NPRM calendar suggests
that he gets this and its value to the
American people watch the communicators
tonight at 8:00 Eastern on c-span 2
Washington Journal continues joining us
from San Francisco is Lauren Wright the
author of the new book on behalf of the
President spouses and White House
communication strategy thank you very
much for being with us here on C's Ben
thank you what was your approach in
writing this well I started with
academic research and the very first
thing I became interested in was
counting speeches made by first ladies
and I found that they speak more often
in public than vice presidents so right
from there I was really fascinated with
why this public activity has been
increasing why first ladies are so
heavily relied upon to communicate the
president's message and really these
different attributes then that they have
that other air surrogates don't you
write the following quote presidential
spouses have made more major public
speeches and remarks than vice
presidents in most years of the last
three presidential administrations vice
presidents are comparable to
presidential spouses because they lack
institutional power except in the Senate
yet play a highly visible role as
presidential running mates so can you
elaborate on that point yes so as I said
first ladies have shouldered more of the
communications burden in the Clinton
Bush and Obama administrations than
those vice-presidential counterparts
have and that is probably the best
comparison we have institutionally and
you know I think this is for a variety
of reasons first ladies are more
interesting to the public by nature they
have higher name recognition than vice
presidents pretty invariably
their evaluations of them are not based
on partisanship in the same way that
Presidents and vice presidents are sort
of saddled with and they're viewed as
outsiders so people view first ladies
differently than government officials
they see them in a more nonpartisan way
and first ladies have more media
flexibility they can go on reality TV
they can go on cooking shows or morning
shows so they are really special
surrogates special representatives and a
lot of attention on the role of Melania
Trump who remains living in New York
until their 10-year old Sunday
his finished school he's in the fourth
grade before living in Washington this
summer and the president talked about
his wife
last Thursday here's what he said I
think that Milani is going to be
outstanding it's right she just opened
up the visitor center in other words
touring of the White House she like
others that she's working with feel very
very strongly about women's issues
women's difficulties very very strongly
and she's a very very strong advocate I
think she's a great representative for
this country and a funny thing happens
because she gets she gets so unfairly
maligned two things they say I've known
her for a long time she was a very
successful person she was a very
successful model she did really well she
would go home at night and didn't even
want to go out with people she was a
very private person she was always the
highest quality that you'll ever find
and the things they say and I've known
it for a long time
the things they say are so unfair and
actually she's been apologized to as you
know by various media because they said
things that were lies I just tell you
this I think she's gonna be a fantastic
first lady she's going to be a
tremendous representative of women and
of the people and helping her and work
in her will be Ivanka who is a fabulous
person and a fabulous fabulous woman and
they're not doing this for money they're
not doing this for pay they're doing
this because they feel that both of them
and Melania goes back and forth and
after Baron finishes school because it's
hard to take a child out of school with
a few months left
she and Baron will be moving over to the
White House kay Lauren right that was
the president last Thursday your
reaction well you know I was just
thinking Steve these are free points
when it comes to the first family I am
so surprised that the Trump
administration has not tried to get even
more exposure with the first family
because when the media addresses the
first family when they address the first
lady when they address first daughters
four sons they are a little bit more
reserved a little bit more friendly by
nature these
aren't people that get tough policy
questions thrown at them so I actually
think for Melania and Ivanka the more
exposure the better the more people who
can talk about President Trump other
than president Trump is going to be a
benefit to the administration right now
I believe you feature the former first
lady Michelle Obama on the cover of your
book here's what she said during the
2016 campaign she because at that moment
I realized that our time in the White
House would form the foundation for who
they would become and how well we
managed this experience could truly make
or break them that is what Barack and I
think about every day as we try to guide
and protect our girls through the
challenges of this unusual life in the
spotlight how we urge them to ignore
those who questioned their fathers
citizenship or faked
[Music]
how we insist that the hateful language
they hear from public figures on TV does
not represent the true spirit of this
country how we explain that when someone
is cruel or acts like a bully you don't
stoop to their level
no our motto is when they go low we go
high
with with every word we utter with every
action we take we know our kids are
watching us we as parents are their most
important role models and let me tell
you Barack and I take that same approach
to our jobs as president and first lady
because we know that our words and
actions matter not just to our girls but
the children across this country and
lorn right we should point out that that
speech that she delivered at the
Democratic National Convention last
summer she never mentioned Donald
Trump's name she was able to thread the
needle talking about her own role as
first lady and as she called herself
first mom and also some of the charges
that Donald Trump leveled against her
husband Barack Obama yes that speech for
a variety of reasons was a real turning
point very important public statements
and actually it was it garnered the most
tweets per minute than any speech either
convention the president's both nominees
and so this is really just an example of
how powerful it is when first lady speak
but not every first lady is such a
talented communicator not every
politician can communicate emotion in
the way mrs. Obama can so it's a
combination of these attributes the
spouse brings that I just talked about
that popularity name recognition
fascination perceived genuine and
authentic remarks and the personal
attributes so Michelle Obama has both
she's a very talented orator and I think
she was very helpful to the campaign
when they needed attention needed a
turning point we're talking with Lauren
right she is a graduate of Wake Forest
earned her doctorate from Georgetown
University and her book on behalf of the
president I also want to ask you about
another role you have and that is as a
board member for the White House
transition project this is a group of
educators looking at the role of
transitions what works and what doesn't
so as you look back at the transition
between our 44th and our 45th president
how did it go for the outgoing
administration and the incoming
administration
well the bush-obama
transition is sort of hailed as the gold
standard for transitions the previous
transitions were not as smooth I think
it's a common misperception that within
party transitions are smoother than out
party transitions and that's actually
not the case a lot of people in Party
assume they might be keeping their jobs
in the bureaucracy and there might be a
little bit of awkwardness asking for
their resignation as far as political
appointees go but that was really the
gold standard and so I do think that the
Obamas tried to emulate that because
that is the experience they had coming
in and so you know President Obama put a
number of pieces of legislation in place
to ensure a smooth transition and to
ensure it started very early and and
really my role with this group for the
first time was to write a piece with
another historian
about the history of the first lady's
office and sort of a best practices
based on the data analysis I did in my
book and other work that scholars have
done in the past our guest who is
joining us from California and later in
the year will be moving to the east
coast teaching at Princeton University
Harold is joining us from Westwood New
Jersey Republican line good morning good
morning well seriously we now have a
situation where Melania Trump publicly
declared the Lord's Prayer I should
recite it now what I won't but there was
an uproar over there our country was
based on essentially when Harvard
started it was a seminary when Rutgers
started it was a Seminary our whole
country was based on allegiance to God
and not only that but for the ten
commandments that is the most important
but obviously the next most important
thing is love your neighbor as yourself
what is so difficult about not only that
love your enemy as yourself now that is
very I am a 94 year old veteran who
served in the US and with the tree
division we must learn to love the
Muslims all those who practice Islam
must be loved by us and it's hard to
believe we should obviously pray that
the terrorists change but even if they
don't we still have to love them now
that is hard to do but we must do it
well Harrell thank you for the call your
94 years old yeah you sound terrific I'd
say you sound more like you're 64 thank
you very much for the call thank you for
your service by the way we had 9,000 we
had 9,000 casualties in our division we
served also with the second British Army
and we served next to a Polish division
and the Polish soldiers hated the
Germans so much we had to take them out
of the line because they would not take
any prisoners all they wanted to do in
that kill kill kill what they taught us
into our american army kill or be killed
we want to do that any what we say love
and be loved this is this is so critical
and for lots of let you say for the sake
of the future generations those people
who are unborn let's let's give a shout
out to the future generations and by the
way I talk on a scapegoat just a minute
we got Nancy Pelosi describe what a
scapegoat is Chuck Schumer and Nancy
Pelosi were the scapegoats for the 20
trillion dollars that put on us by the
last administration Harold I'm going to
stop you there thank you very much for
the call and keep voting and let me go
back though to his earlier point because
he was making a reference to Melania
Trump reading The Lord's Prayer at a
speech in Melbourne Florida on Saturday
Lauren Wright yuria
well I think there were a couple
surprising moments of really good optics
really favorable optics for a president
Trump and that really one I would say
was allowing or encouraging mrs. Trump
to introduce him I think that is always
an opportunity for people to approach a
speech by a president in a different way
as I said maybe a less partisan way he
followed it up with some very divisive
partisan comments but I think allowing
her to speak was a very good decision on
their part and I would also say when
President Trump brought a supporter up
on stage who really appeared to be just
a supporter encourage the Secret Service
to let him onstage I think that was a
moment of relatability and accessibility
for him
presidential spouses and White House
communication strategies today the
subtitle of the book by our guest Glenn
in Buffalo independent line good morning
yes I was really pleased to see that
clip on Michelle Obama's speech I saw it
at the convention now I wasn't at the
convention but I did see the did see it
on television and I guess I was struck
by the tone of it and as an independent
I was watching all the broad categories
of how is this these points and issues
were expressed by both candidates Thank
You Glenn we'll get a response about
Michelle Obama's speech can you tell me
how you would characterize that so I
know more specifically which tone you're
talking about he's actually not on the
line but wanted to get your sense about
her approach to that speech oh sure
well as I said this was a very very well
accepted speech that's an understatement
her convention speeches have been fairly
historic in this manner I'll just refer
back to her 2012 DNC speech just as an
example mrs. Obama's speech was watched
online more than a million times and
President Clinton's speech more than
eight times more than President Obama's
speech so when Michelle Obama appears
there are very high expectations there
are very high expectations for her in
2016 there were so many people watching
and the fact that she delivered these
remarks in a way that resulted in
memorable moments at the Clinton
campaign then used on the campaign trail
I think is pretty commendable former
first lady Laura Bush also sat down with
us and talked about her role as a
teacher a librarian and the start of the
National Book Festival which we
continued to cover every fall here on
c-span - here's part of that interview
started the Texas Book Festival when
George was governor and I thought it was
just a natural to have a National Book
Festival on the big National Mall which
is where it is and it still goes on and
still draws lots and lots of people and
still hugely popular so that was that
weekend the weekend before the Tuesday
morning of September 11th and even on
that morning I was on my way to Capitol
Hill to brief the Senate Education
Committee on early childhood education
I'd hosted a summit on early childhood
education that summer Loren write your
comments on Laura Bush and her role as
this really the instigator behind the
National Book Festival which is now
moved to the convention center but
continues today I think Laura Bush and
like many first lady's was severely
underestimated when she came into office
and she is still underappreciated this
was a highly strategic first lady who
was really a team player really wanted
to help the president wanted to help the
administration and what the bushes did
and what mrs. a Bush specifically did
was she chose initiatives that she had
expertise in yes and she was very
comfortable speaking about education but
that was a very effective frame for the
No Child Left Behind Act and I actually
test test those frames in my book and
numerically people are more supportive
of that Act after seeing a
from mrs. a Bush versus the same exact
one from a vice president or President
Bush and you know she also really broke
new ground with her Afghan women's
initiative and that had a similar effect
people perceived the war on terror
differently after they heard mrs. Bush
talked about Afghan women's issues after
she really framed those efforts abroad
in humanitarian terms rather than
military terms so she helped in a
variety of ways and I think you can find
many similarities in the Obama
administration Michelle Obama really
sought to imitate mrs. Bush in that
manner and do the same thing with her
projects let's go to Linda in Prescott
Arizona Democrats line good morning oh
hi good morning
yes Melania Trump she's a very lovely
lady I think it isn't difficult to see
that whatever was going on between them
has been over a long time ago she seems
very controlled I would say what I'm
going for optics here what do you think
after the America first the the
honeymoon of Trump wears off that a
lovely lady from Slovenia an immigrant
with a heavy foreign accent with no
history United States a model how are
you going to pull the optics to have
that fly for four years should we ever
get in trouble and what what frame of
reference will she be able to to
correlate to make us all feel
comfortable I have nothing against her
personally but this is this is a tough
deal thank you Thank You Linda
we'll see if I could take this question
I think the important starting point is
that the Trump administration has not
had a honeymoon phase as most presidents
do when they come into office he's below
40 percent favorability in some polls
I've seen I think that's about the worst
we've seen so far for him and so mrs.
Trump I believe could be playing a very
important role right now both from a
perspective of distraction and an
enhancing her husband's public image
when Melania Trump appears on television
people are very interested she's kept
her powder dry we don't know very much
about her she hasn't made very many
appearances so those appearances by
nature will be high impact when she does
make them and that's positive for the
administration again these are positive
interviews in which she is usually not
asked a tough question what I'll also
say is staying in New York is so
different from what we've seen by the
way but it does not help the
administration's overall arching
communications strategy if you could
identify one which is really the
president as someone who's slashing
budgets who's streamlining government
and the high cost of keeping mrs. Trump
in New York and the high cost of the
Trump's travel over the last few weeks
is not consistent with that and so I
think there are many things she could be
doing of course
many parents most parents can relate to
wanting to do what's best for your
children but I think there are untapped
opportunities when it comes to mrs.
Trump I think if we saw her more often
in public then it's possible her
favorables could go up and I think we'd
have a better idea of of who this person
is and her relationship with the
president which is what Americans are
really interested in 202 seven four
eight eight thousand one for Republicans
in 202 7 for 8 eight thousand for
democrats our guest is Lauren Wright and
another excerpt from your new book on
presidential spouses you write the
following the number of speeches that
have been politicized through covert
rather than overt mentions of policy has
greatly increased the White House
communications operations may have
discovered a new way to exercise the
public appeal of presidential spouses
political advocacy in an apolitical
context can you explain
that's absolutely right so I just
mentioned Laura Bush is ready to read
ready to learn project and how important
that was as a frame for No Child Left
Behind and her involvement in that and
her Afghan women's initiatives and the
effect those had on perceptions of the
war on
terror at a time that the president
really needed it a similar thread can be
found in the Obama administration mrs.
Obama chose childhood obesity as her
number one her first issue she's
actually the first lady to have
professionally staffed initiatives
initiative by initiative with specific
people assigned to specific projects but
really that was an effective a frame for
the Affordable Care Act in communication
strategy of any kind consistency is key
so you want to MIT send a simple message
and a consistent message and so it was
so important that mrs. Obama's policy
agenda if you will was linked and very
understandably so to the president's you
can see the same thing with the
president's announcement to withdraw
troops from Iraq and Afghanistan she
launched and pursued joining forces her
military and veterans initiative for
military families at that point so it's
important to understand when it comes to
first lady's these are key strategic
players and they can help shape the
public image of the president yes but
also of the president's policy agenda
these are not people that are bystanders
they're not you know people who are
taken for granted by the administration
these are key players there in many ways
the MVP of the White House our guest is
dr. Lauren Wright she earned her PhD in
government from Georgetown University
Calvin is joining us from Lexington
Massachusetts Republican line good
morning
hi mrs. Wright and thank you for taking
my call I was thinking that Melania
Trump is much more immature than
Michelle Obama saying that she's having
uh she's going back with the ten year
old in school and I feel as though that
that's kind of showing that she almost
values her family more than she does the
White House even though I mean her
husband is the President of the United
States so let's get a response Thank You
Calvin
well I'm hesitant to characterize
anything as immature without seeing data
on this we don't know how the public
feels specifically about mrs. Trump's
decision to
in New York and not move into the White
House so in the absence of that I would
point to her favorables which are low
about 51% according to a morning consult
poll of people want to see her play an
active role as first lady but I think
she was at about 47 percent favorability
last time and that is lower than past
first lady's and so if there is a
connection and people are paying
attention closely to what mrs. Trump is
doing and I suspect they are for the
most part then then she is not as
favored as past first ladies have been
Judy is joining us Baltimore Democrats
line good morning good morning
the problem with Melania Trump and the
Lord's Prayer is because the Lord's
Prayer was taken out of school and if
you take the Lord's Prayer out of school
and children lost you know certain
values during that time and then people
King I think a lot of people can't get
past seeing her new because I see that I
always told my daughter what you do as a
young woman will follow you as an old
woman because you don't know what you're
going to do in life this is why she's
gonna have a lot of problems being a
first lady like Laura Bush Michelle
Obama very classy women mrs. Kennedy
classy women people can't get past that
image have a good dish Judy thank you
what about those pictures Lauren right
well I think people were able to get
past this in a way that perhaps we would
not have anticipated based on history
you know mrs. Trump was not apologetic
about her nude photo shoot she said I'm
proud of my body this was done as a work
of art and very differently from
previous administrations and what we
would expect from political campaigns
she did not try to appease conservative
Republicans she did not say that she
regretted this decision and so really
the way she tackled this head-on I think
is something that's both different
and perhaps from a communication
standpoint a step forward even if
Americans don't agree with the behavior
specifically she was very direct about
that and pretty honest with regard to
this particular issue let me ask you
about another modern First Lady Hillary
Clinton and the starting gate of her
husband's tenure in the White House she
focused on health care testified before
Congress Americans can no longer wait
for health care reform as we sit here
today literally hundreds and hundreds of
Americans will lose their health care
insurance hundreds and hundreds of
families will make a decision to
postpone getting that primary or
preventive health care because they
cannot afford it thousands more will
show up at the doors of our emergency
rooms to seek help because it is the
only place available to them
business owners both large and small
will be struggling with insurance
premium increases and trying to figure
out how to keep doing the right thing
for themselves and their employees the
task confronting us is complex but it is
urgent the American people rightly are
watching all of us they are impatient
but they are also hopeful they want
change they expect change they deserve
change and they want to see the
government at the highest levels work
for them they want to know that we have
heard their stories
last week the president outlined for
Congress a plan that will provide health
care for every American health care that
can never be taken away as the president
said and as he believes this is not a
partisan issue it is not an ideological
battle it is a problem to be solved that
affects all of us and if all of us put
beyond politics as usual open ourselves
up to look at whatever evidence comes
our way to scrutinize that and to
analyze it we will respond to the needs
the American public have in 1993 Hillary
Clinton then first lady testifying on
health care interestingly that issue
continued in the campaign of 2016 but
your thoughts as you look back at that
archival soundbite well this issue with
Hillary Clinton in the Health Security
Act and it was declared dead in Congress
in the summer of 1994 has been dissected
and studied by political scientists and
historians alike and a few conclusions
have come out of it there's a couple
reason why that messaging strategy that
she adopted failed the first is despite
speaking about how this is a non
partisan issue
testifying on the hill is a very
politicized partisan policy-making move
for her and so when first ladies have
pursued policy explicitly it's important
for them to downplay the policy-making
role or the appearance of one even
though they often do shape policy and
really emphasize this outsider status
that they have that's one of the most
valuable qualities first ladies bring to
messaging strategy when they go outside
Washington when they travel around the
United States
they are often received in a much more
favorable manner and actually once
Hillary Clinton started doing this when
she pursued foster care legislation for
example she was much better received so
I think there were a lot of lessons
learned from that evidence by the fact
that mrs. Bush and mrs. Obama did not
try to play such an explicit
policymaking role they provided their
input behind the scenes they were
important in that regard and they wanted
their comments incorporated but they
delegated them to trusted aides and they
sort of strayed away from these
from the appearance of policymaking even
though mrs. Bush did also testify on the
hill we'll go to New Mexico next to
Linda is on the phone from Hurley New
Mexico independent line good morning
good morning my comment is when I watch
Melania she sort of reminds me of Jackie
very quiet dignified I just wanna know
what your guests thought Linda thank you
I have heard this so much and I think
there are obvious similarities you know
mrs. mrs. Kennedy and mrs. mrs. Trump
obviously have similar fashion taste and
mrs. Trump was said to have channeled
that during the inauguration exactly
right on with this quiet demeanor the
perception of someone who's very private
that's exactly right
but I think that overall this is a
little bit oversimplified because really
mrs. Kennedy you have to think about it
was such a strategist no matter what was
going on in her marriage no matter what
was happening in the Kennedy
administration
she knew the value of her public
appearances she knew people wanted to
see her and she absolutely delivered on
that she allowed media to interviewed
her she was not fond of it she didn't
even want to be called the first lady by
people within the White House but she
did these things anyway and so I think
that's a little bit where mrs. Trump
diverges I think there are other first
ladies perhaps who might resemble her
more as far as actions but you're
absolutely right with the demeanor and
the fashion sense and Loren right in her
remaining minute with you what about the
role of Lady Bird Johnson during her
husband's administration oh I'd love to
talk about Lady Bird Johnson because she
was really the first spouse to campaign
independently of her husband on the
campaign trail she was really such a
force in 1960 and 1964 President Johnson
was hesitant to go to the south after
the Civil Rights Act was passed and so
he sent his his most trusted delegate
his wife down there because she had
Southern roots she knew people in the
south she
felt that she could communicate with
people better than perhaps even he could
and so she made great strides in the way
of campaigning in particular on behalf
of the President
presidential spouses and White House
communication strategy today the book by
our guest Lauren Wright up early in San
Francisco thank you very much for being
with us please come back again thank you
we want to turn our attention to a tweet
that's been getting a fair amount of
media attention over the last couple of
days Donald Trump the President of the
United States saying that he inherited a
mess this is the tweet that was issued
last week don't believe the mainstream
fake news media the White House is
running very well I inherited a mess and
I'm in the process of fixing it so our
question did the president inherit a
mess for Republicans 202 seven four
eight eight thousand one if you're a
Democrat 202 seven four eight 8004
independence 202 seven four eight eight
thousand two we also have a line for
those watching outside the United States
we welcome our listeners on c-span radio
here's the president last week talking
about this very issue in Melbourne
Florida we are here today to speak the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth
I hear you demands I hear your voices
and I promise you I will deliver I
promise that
and by the way you've seen what we've
accomplished in a very short period of
time the White House is running so
smoothly so smoothly and believe me I
and we inherited one big mess so based
on that did he again give us a call or
send us a tweet at c-span WJ did
president Donald J Trump inherit a mess
from the Obama White House well this is
a question that was posed on the sunday
shows with the Chris Wallace of the Fox
News Channel and also by Chuck Todd of
NBC's Meet the Press the White House
chief of staff
Reince Priebus responding to Chuck
Todd's question about how the White
House is operating look if there's a
problem there those people will have big
issues but the truth is is that we don't
have problems in the West Wing I mean
you read about all these stories if I
don't get along with Bannen and this one
said actually we've really gelled as a
team
and we get along great and we're working
well together and the amount of drama
and spin that you read about mostly in
the Washington daily gossip rags is
unbelievable stuff and it just isn't
true and you read it every day and you
wonder what alternative universe they're
reporting on because it just isn't true
I think every West Wing has different
personalities you had Rahm Emanuel
Valerie Jarrett David Axelrod yet and
ecard Karl Rove you always have
different kinds of people but it doesn't
mean that you don't ultimately get along
serve the president want to make the
American people proud that's what we're
doing every day that's what we're trying
to do every day the former chair of the
Republican National Committee and now
White House chief of staff Reince
Priebus from mar-a-lago Florida the
president is there till still today
returning to the White House tonight
this is the cover story of Time magazine
nothing to see here as a hurricane
encircling President Trump from the oval
office of the White House Roberta is
joining us from Dayton Ohio Democrats
line did the president inherit a mess no
the President did not inherit a man
and why why do you say that well because
there anyone that has paid any attention
and follows what the media is reporting
which is not fake news except for what
he put out there his he himself he along
with his followers spoke highly daily on
what was fake news because they created
it in order to discredit Hillary Clinton
and everybody is seeing what's going on
he created this ugly news he loved it
and it's it's benefited him but he still
he's crying about it every time he turns
TV on it's it's such a sad case to see
this man has become the president of the
United States and he's lying
more every day it's just a sad case
Roberta on the Democrats line from
Dayton Ohio a tweet from maverick come
on Washington journal really going to
give credence to Trump's I inherited a
mess statement how low is the bar well
he tweeted on it he spoke about it over
the weekend in Melbourne Florida at a
campaign rally that we carried live and
so we want to get your reaction did he
inherit a mess this is from another
viewer saying Trump is incapable of
comprehending the complexity of the
presidency of course it looks like a
mess on the Republican line from South
Carolina Mike is next good morning
mister good mone
go ahead please yeah thank you for the
call
yeah just like Butler the last guest you
had on they was talking about how
welcome I mean the wife of Donald Trump
the president and Donald Trump they
attack her daily in the news their
attacker kids did that ever happen to
Michelle Obama you know on all the news
stations and did he inherited miss
Obamacare we all part-timers out here
now that were there low-paying jobs they
dropped her hours from 40 or more hours
down to 30 hours or less no insurance
I insurance premiums yeah the veterans
is did the last administration take care
of the veterans and she was talking
about how many people died a not having
insurance how about the veterans how
many of them commit suicide a day
because they can't even get seen by the
VA which Donald Trump will fix and he'll
fix his jobs just ask people from West
Virginia Pennsylvania Ohio that he's
going to bring back to John's there
thank you sir Mike from South Carolina
thank you Mark Walsh has this tweet a
mess is an understatement he says the
national debt Libya Syria Iraq the
country is divided like never before
well PolitiFact is also writing about
Donald Trump's tweets and his comments
over the weekend because quote a mess is
a subjective term writes politifact we
decided not to rate his statement on our
truth-o-meter instead we'll look some of
the hard numbers and let readers make up
their own minds for example we should
note that no president is all-powerful
in controlling the economy global market
forces changes in technology oil shocks
and random events play roles as well the
president Donald Trump was handed the
reins of an economy with a 4.7 percent
unemployment rate 75 consecutive months
of job growth rising stock prices home
values corporate profits and consumer
confidence as well as low inflation on
the Republican line Travis is next from
Grand Prairie Texas good morning did the
president inherited mess yes I think he
inherited a complete catastrophe I don't
think a hurricane could win and Donna is
much damaged the political hurricane so
I think he had to go into office behind
probably is going to go down in history
as one of the worst presidents we've
ever had I think the former president
only showed it success just because of
the mentality of the people that support
him most of his people that voted for
him don't even know the issues out there
today you can go out on the streets and
ask them
which numerous television programs do
and you can ask them about different
issues and they they don't have an ideal
what you're even talking about
Travis thanks for the call let's go on
the Democrats line Roseanne is next from
Wisconsin
good morning yes I'm calling on behalf
of President Obama I can't believe what
I'm hearing people's memories must be
very short because he had to bail out
the banks and the auto industry and the
housing industry and we were bleeding
jobs at like eight thousand a month and
to try to repair that mess and the Iraq
war
I mean trillions of dollars there and
billions of dollars on pallets that
people don't even know where it went I
just have a comment that President Trump
really needs to go back in and and look
at his comments because I think that
President Obama did has done a wonderful
job and to care enough about the
American people to want to make sure
that everybody has good health care I
believe that it is a right and not a
privilege if you want a really good
viable working middle class you have to
have a healthy middle class and I just
like to say thank you c-span watch you
every day and told your on ok
Roseanne thanks for the call a lot of
attention about the upcoming state visit
that the president will have in Great
Britain he was formally invited by Queen
Elizabeth and The Guardian newspaper
this morning reporting that the
President of the United States will
receive the full courtesy of a state
visit when that occurs our next caller
is from Silver Spring Maryland Stacy
independent line good morning welcome to
the conversation yes he no he did not
inherit a mess not at all he's
constantly said things you know that
truth Stacy thank you for the call
well here's more from the president at
that campaign rally and another story
that's been getting a 10
in his comments about Sweden and we'll
show you the reaction from the Swedish
government but first from Melbourne
Florida here's President Trump look at
what's happening last night in Sweden
Sweden who would believe this Sweden
they took in large numbers they're
having problems like they never thought
possible you look at what's happening in
Brussels you look at what's happening
all over the world take a look at nice
take a look at Paris we've allowed
thousands and thousands of people into
our country and there was no way to vet
those people there was no documentation
there was no nothing so we're going to
keep our country safe the comments of
the president in Melbourne Florida the
full speech on our website at c-span org
we carried it live on Saturday this
response from the Embassy of Sweden we
look forward to informing the United
States administration about Swedish
immigration and integration policies and
president Trump explaining my statement
as to what's happening in Sweden was in
reference to a story that was broadcast
on the Fox News Channel
concerning immigrants and Sweden that
program that aired Friday evening let's
go to Lynn joining us from California
independent line did the president
inherited mess good morning good morning
yes I believe he did and I believe Obama
inherited mess and Bush inherited mess
and it goes back for so many years it's
just completely ridiculous that all of a
sudden Trump inherited this mess and you
know my question is you know when you
look at all these senators and
congressmen that have been there for 30
or 40 years come on and talk about some
of the problems and trying to blame the
current president it's it's basically
laughable and the thing that I listened
to your show every day like a lot of the
other callers that call in and you know
I just fully believe that none of us
American people that are just getting up
and going to work every day and trying
to keep our families together and our
lives together have a clue as to what's
going on in Washington DC and I think if
you're
Republican Democrat or independent that
we're all getting completely ripped off
from the government and I just wish that
there was term limits you know it makes
me sick to see you know McCain and and
Schumer and all those senators get up
and talk about these same problems and
it's like you guys have been there for
30-some plus years so to blame it on
Trump and it's just completely
ridiculous or Obama or Clinton or any
president that's it does in Harran a
mess because of how out-of-control
Washington DC is and that's what I
really hope that people start paying
attention to and just be kind to Donald
Trump if you don't like him it doesn't
matter but we're trying to we're
spending all this money on anti-bullying
programs in our schools maybe we need to
spend a lot of money on some
anti-bullying programs for these people
so they could just give Trump a break
you know that's what what I just really
think needs to happen so anything I
think whoever president it's gonna be a
mess until from Bishop in California
thanks for the call a couple of tweets
we want to share with you this is from
Steve let's talk about Ness angering
Mexico Australia Sweden missile tests
from Iran Russia North Korea and that's
just the first month and another tweet
from this viewer saying first Obama
could not do anything because of
Republicans next Obama did a wonderful
job which one was it both ways question
mark well market watch is also reporting
on whether or not the president
inherited a mess in describing the
economy at market watch calm the writers
say context is important and without
taking anything away from the challenges
that Trump faces overseas a few things
should be noted the economy adding two
hundred and twenty seven thousand jobs
last month that according to the first
jobs report of the Trump administration
far surpassing that predicted one
hundred eighty thousand by economists
wages are rising they're up two point
nine percent from last year adding about
seventy five cents to the average hourly
pay inflation a solid two point five
percent context matters well by the way
the president just a few months ago
tweeting on this president
day here's what he said at the real
Donald Trump happy Presidents Day make
America great again Marian is joining us
from Sebring Florida Republican line
good morning good morning
you're on the air go ahead please yes
good morning my name is Mona in I'm
Hispanic American and I have a couple of
points that I need to point out
yes president Trump inherited a mess and
here is my base are failing schools the
system the education system is a mess
point number two immigration I saw
insist and an interview the Congress had
with immigration officials they cannot
even give the numbers of how many people
came in or out of the United States the
last report that they had was from I
believe 1994 we don't have exact numbers
of who is here or who are here in the
United States that is a mess third point
leaks in the White House lack of ethics
why do we have people working for the
president that they cannot keep their
mouth shut
they had to give her way or the secret
number four we have a divided nation
these divided nations because we can now
respect who is in power right now
Mariner from Florida thanks very much
for the call Hugh has this tweet Sweden
is the bowling-green
of Europe and another tweet just a
moment ago from President Trump give the
public a break the thick news media
trying to say that large-scale
immigration in Sweden is working out
just beautifully not exclamation mark
says the president Joe is next from
Columbia South Carolina good morning
you're welcome to the program good
morning sir
go ahead please yes sir well myself did
not inherited miss I mean who woke
inherited a man was a mr. Obama
you know unemployment work nearly
11-percent he got it down in less than
5% how is that amiss also he did not all
the good things too now now we do need
to work on the traditional system you
know for for us the way some of the
african-americans brothers have been
shut down in the street unarmed most of
them teenagers and all of it we need to
work on that now but I don't respect the
Trump even Kerala also we got a lot of
problem with the opioids you know over
at epidemic has hit a lot of part of
this country
here they cares about a Hillary had a
program that's kind of combat this
previous Trump's you know in all kind of
problems and a semi inheritor myth well
whatever whatever amiss or crisis he
will face you're not gonna be able to do
it because you know how to print out of
it how the makeup to deal with any of it
so American made a huge mistake and
putting this this idiot in office you
know and I don't understand how why so
many people drink that poison his Trump
kool-aid every day
later Joe from South Carolina thanks for
the call the Chicago Tribune reporting
on another round of protests and
demonstrations in the Windy City on an
unusually mild day protesters taking the
streets yesterday afternoon in the
Chicago Loop area voicing their concerns
about a number of the president's agenda
items including immigration issues with
a police escort several hundred people
marching from Trump Tower to Federal
Plaza expressing displeasure with the
administration this court paused travel
ban its policies on immigrants in the US
without legal permission and has
promised to build a wall along the
us-mexico border
dori is next from Palmyra New Jersey
Democrats lying good morning good
morning sir thank you for having me I
really appreciate it
I am just so repelled of this man that
isn't power it's scary to me I am my
husband I talk about it every day
I am frightened I'm an old lady okay but
I am frightened for the young 17 18 19
20 21 year old kids that this lunatic is
going to throw into a wall
that's my scare that's my fear
I pray on it every night sir and I hope
all these people who have called I've
been listening to it that are so proud
Trump what is wrong with them I mean
what is really wrong with them this man
is a lunatic we have a lunatic for our
president it's scary to me it's scary to
my husband I mean world people we see
here in Croke that's fine okay but I
really worry about the young kids this
world
and I worry about my grandchildren that
are going to come up and hear this kind
of rhetoric it's it's frightening to me
to worry from New Jersey thank you and
this is a similar point of view from
Tony this tweet Trump is the mess we
inherited and this comment from a viewer
saying thank you to the California
caller this has been a mess really for
the last thirty years what did read my
lips really mean foolish people we'll go
to Jay joining us on our independent
line from Illinois good morning Jay hey
that's a great question it's taking
inherited the complexity of the
presidency foreign policy is very
complex trying to build people together
and get past a gridlock that's very
complex so you kind of muddle through
ins in some regard but any objective
measure you look at the economy any
objective measure clearly we're on the
upswing so that should be unabated but
if you look at all the economists in
terms of the measures that we use to
determine recessions and so forth stock
market housing prices and so forth
clearly there's tremendous improvement
but the the one caller alluded to the
fact that the immigration policy it
again that goes back to the bipartisan
effort to gridlock so that is very
complex so the use of term